y criar al resto de los hijos
y así no tener que lidiar con todo lo relacionado con la discapacidad.
No creía a mi padre, no porque fuera un mentiroso,
sino porque nunca había oído esta historia
y mi madre, de hecho, la validó.
Ella nunca quiso contármela.
Pero en realidad, no entiendo por qué estaba tan sorprendida con esta historia,
porque cuando tenía 5 años,
y mi madre, como las madres y padres en todo EE. UU.,
me llevó a la escuela para inscribirme,
empujó mi silla de ruedas a la escuela a poca distancia de nuestra casa,
levantó la silla por los escalones dentro de la escuela,
y fuimos recibidos por el director.
No realmente recibidos.
Pero como dijo el director, no, no podía ir a esa escuela
porque ésta no era accesible.
Pero él dijo que no nos preocupáramos,
porque la Junta de Educación enviaría un profesor a mi casa.
Y ellos lo hicieron
por un total de dos horas y media
una semana.
(la Audiencia murmura)
Pero por buen comportamiento,
me llevaron a un terapeuta ocupacional
quien me enseñó habilidades muy esenciales
de punto de cruz.
(Risas)
No hago punto de cruz ahora.
No pude ir a la escuela en un edificio real
hasta que tuve 9 años,
y estaba en clase sólo con niños discapacitados
en una escuela que tenía principalmente niños sin discapacidades.
Y en mis clases,
había estudiantes de más de 21 años.
Y entonces, después de los 21,
ellos iban a algo llamado talleres protegidos
con trabajo doméstico
y no ganaban nada o por debajo del salario mínimo.
Así entendí la discriminación.
Mis padres entendieron la discriminación.
Mis padres son de Alemania.
Fueron judíos alemanes que se marcharon en la década de 1930,
escapando del Holocausto.
Mis padres perdieron familia y a sus padres.
Ambos perdieron a sus padres durante el Holocausto.
Así se dieron cuenta
de que no podía quedarse callados
cuando las cosas iban mal en mi vida.
No me afectaban directamente
pero lo que estaba pasando a mi alrededor.
Ellos aprendieron que porque usaba silla de ruedas,
ningún instituto en Nueva York, en la ciudad entera,
era accesible para silla de ruedas,
¿qué se suponía que iba a pasar?
¿se suponía que volvería a la enseñanza en casa?
al igual que muchos otros estudiantes.
Mis padres se unieron con otros padres.
Fueron a la Junta Educativa
y exigieron a la Junta hacer algunos institutos accesibles.
Y ellos lo hicieron.
Y yo y muchos otros
pudimos al final ir al instituto, un instituto normal,
y tomar clases normales.
¿Qué ocurrió después?
Aprendí más y más sobre lo que era la discriminación,
e igualmente importante, aprendí que necesitaba ser mi propia defensora.
Estaba entrando en la universidad, la Universidad de Long Island,
y siempre quise ser profesora,
estudié educación y tomé todos los cursos apropiados,
y cuando llegó el momento de ir a por mi licencia,
tuve que hacer un examen escrito,
y un examen oral
y un examen médico.
Todos esos tres exámenes
fueron presentados en edficios completamente inaccesibles,
así que tenía amigos cargándome escaleras arriba y abajo
por estos exámenes,
no en una silla motorizada.
(Risas)
En una silla manual.
Pero pasé mi examen oral.
Pasé mi examen escrito.
Mi examen médico fue algo completamente diferente.
Una de las primeras preguntas que me hizo el médico
fue, si le podía enseñar cómo iba al baño.
Tenía 22 años
y Uds. saben cuando vas a cualquier tipo de entrevista
y piensas en todas las posibles preguntas que la gente preguntará
(Risas)
Esa no era una de ellas.
Y en primer lugar me asusté
porque había oído
que actualmente había gente no discapacitada usando silla de ruedas
que eran profesores en Nueva York,
así que en cada paso del camino estaba esperando algo malo.
Así que le dije,
¿Es un requerimiento que los profesores enseñen
cómo ir al baño?
Si lo es, puedo hacerlo.
Así que sin sorpresas,
yo fallé
porque no pasé el examen médico.
La razón oficial por la que se me denegó mi trabajo
fue la parálisis de las secuelas de la polimielitis. Lo siento.
Parálisis de ambos miembros inferiores, secuela de la poliomielitis.
Honestamente, no supe que significaba "secuela",
así que fui al diccionario y significaba "a consecuencia de."
Me habían denegado mi licencia porque no podía andar.
¿Qué iba a hacer?
Es una época realmente importante de mi vida,
porque sería la primera vez
que realmente debería enfrentar al sistema, yo,
y a pesar de que trabajaba con un montón de amigos con discapacidades
que me animaban a seguir adelante con esto,
Sin embargo, era bastante aterrador.
Pero fui muy afortunada.
Un amigo que era un estudiante en la la Universidad de Long Island.
y era también corresponsal en el "New York Times,"
y era capaz de conseguir una reportaje
y escribir un buen artículo sobre lo que había ocurrido
y por qué él pensó que lo que había pasado estaba mal.
Al día siguiente había una editorial en el "New York Times"
con el título "Heumann contra La Junta Escolar"
y el "New York Times" salió en apoyo
de conseguir mi licencia de profesor.
(Aplausos)
Y entonces en el mismo día,
recibí una llamada de un abogado que escribía un libro sobre derechos civiles.
Y me llamaba para entrevistarme,
Y yo estaba entrevistándole a él.
Él no sabía esto.
Y al final de nuestra discusión, dije,
"¿Estarías dispuesto a representarme?. Quiero demandar a la Junta Educativa."
Y él dijo sí.
Ahora, a veces digo que las estrellas se alinearon en este caso,
porque tuvimos un juez increíble:
la primera jueza federal afroamericana.
(Risas)
Constance Baker Motley.
(Aplausos)
Y sabía qué era discriminación en cuando lo vio.
(Risas)
Ella alentó fuertemente a la Junta
a hacerme otro examen médico,
lo cual hicieron.
Y entonces conseguí mi licencia,
y aunque me costó unos meses
conseguir que un director me ofreciera un trabajo,
finalmente conseguí un trabajo y empecé a enseñar ese otoño
en la misma escuela que tuve que ir
en segundo grado.
Así que...
(Aplausos)
Esa es otra charla para TED Talk.
(Risas)
Pero aprendí igual que mis amigos lo hicieron,
y otra gente a lo largo del país que no conozco,
que debíamos ser nuestros defensores,
que necesitabamos luchar contra las perspectivas de otros
que si tuvieras discapacidad, necesitabas ser curado,
que la igualdad no era parte de la ecuación.
Y aprendimos de el Movimiento de Derechos Civiles
y el Movimiento de Derechos de la Mujer.
Estabamos aprendiendo de ellos sobre su activismo
y su habilidad para unirse,
no sólo para discutir problemas
sino para discutir soluciones.
Y lo que nació es lo que hoy llamamos Movimiento de Derechos de la Discapacidad.
Me gustaría contarles un par de acertijos.
¿Cuánta gente se necesita
para parar el tráfico de Madison Avenue
durante hora punta en Nueva York?
¿Alguna pista?, ¿Cuántos?
(la Audiencia grita respuestas)
50.
Uno sería muy poco.
50 personas.
y no había furgonetas accesibles,
así que tenían que tratar con nosotros.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Permítanme contarles otro acertijo.
¿Cuánta gente hace falta para parar un bus en Nueva York
cuando ellos se niegan a dejarte pasar por estar en silla de ruedas?.
Uno. Esa es la respuesta correcta.
Entonces lo que hay que hacer
es llevar tu silla de ruedas,
(Risas)
acercarse sigilosamente al lugar correcto justo frente a los escalones
y dar un pequeño empujón debajo,
y entonces el bus no puede movese.
(Risas)
Cualquiera de Uds. que quiera aprender cómo hacerlo,
hablen conmigo después.
(Risas)
En 1972, el presidente Nixon vetó la Ley de rehabilitación.
Protestamos. Él la firmó.
Las regulaciones que necesitaban ser promulgadas para implementar esta ley
de hecho no habían sido firmadas.
Lo demostramos. Fueron firmadas.
Y cuando "Los estadounidenses con discapacidades actúan", el ADA,
o nuestro acto de proclamación de emancipación,
parecía que no podía ser aprobada por la Cámara o el Senado,
gente discapacitada de todo EE. UU. se reunió
y se arrastraron por las escalones del Capitolio.
Fue un día increíble,
y la Cámara y el Senado aprobaron la ADA.
Y el presidente Bush firmó la ADA.
Una gran imagen.
El presidente Bush firmó el ADA en el césped de la Casa Blanca.
Fue un día increíble,
y allí hay cerca de 2000 personas.
Era el 26 de Julio, 1990.
Y una de las declaraciones más famosas en su discurso
fue ,"Dejen que las vergonzosas paredes de la exclusión finalmente caigan."
Para cualquiera en la sala
que tenga 50 años o más, o quizás 40 o más,
recuerdan un tiempo cuando no había rampas en las calles,
los buses no eran accesibles,
los trenes no eran accesibles,
no había cuartos de baño accesibles en los centros comerciales,
donde no había a un intérprete de lengua de signos,
o subtítulos, o braille u otro tipo de apoyos.
Estas cosas han cambiado
y han inspirado al mundo.
Y la gente discapacitada de todo el mundo quiere leyes como las que tenemos,
y quieren que estas leyes se cumplan.
Y lo que hemos visto es algo llamado
la Convención de los Derechos de Personas con discapacidad.
Es un tratado que fue adoptado en 2006.
Se celebra el 10º aniversario.
Más de 165 países se han unidado a este tratado.
Es el primer tratado internacional de derechos humanos
enfocado por completo en discapacitados.
Pero tristemente he de decir que el Senador de EE. UU.
no pudo recordar a nuestro presidente que nosotros ratificamos el tratado.
Lo firmamos en 2009,
pero no tiene vigor hasta su ratificación,
y el presidente, ningún presidente puede ratificar un tratado
sin el consentimiento del Senado.
Sentimos con intensidad
que el Senado debe hacer su trabajo,
que nuestro Senado debe permitirnos como estadounidenses
no solo ayudar a personas discapacitadas y a gobiernos de todo el mundo
a aprender sobre el buen trabajo que hemos estado haciendo,
sino, es igualmente importante
que las personas con discapacidad tengan las mismas oportunidades
para viajar, estudiar y trabajar fuera
como cualquiera en nuestro país.
Mientras muchos países no tengan las mismas leyes que nosotros
y no las apliquen teniéndolas,
las oportunidades para gente con discapacidad serán más limitadas.
Cuando viajamos fuera,
siempre encuentro a mujeres discapacitadas
y ellas me cuentan sus historias
sobre cómo experimentan la violencia y violación
y como en muchos casos estas formas de violencia
vienen de miembros de la familia y gente que ellas conocen,
quienes están trabajando para ellas.
Y frecuentemente estos casos no son adjudicados.
Conozco a gente discapacitada
a quienes empresas les han ofrecido trabajos
porque viven en un país con un sistema de cuota,
y para evitar una multa,
ellos te contratarán
y luego te dirán
"No necesitas venir al trabajo
porque no te necesitamos en la empresa."
He visitado instituciones
donde el hedor a orina es tan fuerte
que antes de que abras la puerta de tu vehículo,
te ha tirado para atrás,
y entonces fui a instituciones
donde la gente debería vivir en comunidad con apoyos apropiados
y he visto gente casi desnuda,
gente drogada con medicamentos
y gente viviendo sus vidas con desesperación.
Son algunas de las cosas en las que el país debe hacer más por corregir.
Conocemos la discriminación al verla,
y necesitamos enfrentarla juntos.
¿Qué es lo que podemos hacer juntos?
Les animo a Uds. a admitir que
la discapacidad es una familia a la que podrían unirse en un momento de su vida.
Me gustaría ver a mano alzada ¿cuántos se han roto un hueso?
y cuando se vayan hoy, me gustaría que escribieran un par de frases
sobre un periodo de tiempo que haya sido similar para Ud.
porque frecuentemente escucho decir,
"No podría hacer esto, no podría hacer aquello.
La gente me habla diferente. Actúan diferente conmigo."
Y eso es lo que veo y otros discapacitados ven
en letras luminosas.
Pero Uds. en esta sala,
la gente que está escuchando y viendo esta TED Talk ,
juntos podemos hacer una diferencia.
Juntos podemos pedir justicia.
Juntos podemos ayudar a cambiar el mundo.
Gracias. Tengo que tomar mi autobús.
(Aplausos)